ready good morning everyone all right
though it was off to a good start
there's easy I'm gonna talk today about
how everyone is getting pwned and I want
to try and give you loads of examples
give you some sort of technical stuff
and regale you with stories of the cyber
as well this will be fun now one of the
things that happened when I talk to
people about getting pwned is they get a
little bit confused about what I mean by
the term and the geico or what does it
mean I get pwned and it's it's funny
because often I'm speaking to like the
media or like normal non-technical
people and they have not heard this term
before and I have to try and find ways
to explain what the word means and there
are there are many ways of doing this so
I have a little clip here of one way of
getting pwned which is quite different
to to many of the ways we deal with that
is definitely pwned I often do this talk
overseas and when I go over there
they're all fascinated about Australia
so I say well look when we're in
Australia and you get pwned it actually
looks a lot more like this and they love
it they go nuts getting more to this
sort of InfoSec cyber side of things
another way of being pwned would be to
be a French journalist talking about how
your Twitter account got pwned whilst
the password to your Twitter account are
pasted on the wall behind you this is
also being pwned now a lot of the reason
we're using this word and a lot of
things going to talk to you about today
I related to this system has anyone used
have I been poned before alright look at
that who's been inside the drop box data
breach LinkedIn data breach Ashley
Madison data breach always a guy every
single time now in all seriousness we
know it was basically all guys and I
know that this is not a particularly
surprising thing given the nature of the
site but we know it was pretty much all
guys because after they got breached and
all their data just got spread out over
the web when people analyzed where the
users signed up from women had an
interestingly high prevalence of signing
up from IP address 127.0.0.1
one and I bots right there just
manufactured bots that ran in the system
to engage with men so that they thought
they had a better chance of fulfilling
their objective of being on the site in
the first place and they'd pay more
money and the interesting thing about
seeing data breaches like this is that
when the data breach happens we start to
see all of these internal mechanisms of
how things work inside the organization
well almost like a little bit of a
lesson there like imagine all your data
was public and all of your decisions and
business practices were in the public
domain because this is happening quite a
lot now one of the things that I find
very interesting is there are some
really cool sophisticated security
controls we don't talk about some of
these today and there's also some really
fundamentally basic things that still go
wrong and I thought I'd pick an example
and I kata the penny dropped on me today
when I walked in here's a lot of cba
people here right
so anyway I got a slide and I did a
talk in in London a few months ago and
they said you know can you sort of do
something that talks about like
sophisticated security but also have
some of the really fundamental stuff
goes wrong and one of the interesting
things that that came out of this whole
banking Royal Commission is CBA had to
say look we we had an incident we
misplaced lost not sure exactly what the
term was it could not account for some
data that was part of a decommission a
little while ago part of a datacenter
decommission and the way the story was
represented and you guys can tell me if
I was right or wrong about this as well
it's a lot of blue threw us with CBA
anyway the way the story was presented
as I said look we were decommissioning a
data center and we put the data on the
truck to take it for Destruction and
I've got some file footage with the
truck here and this is the this is the
CBA data on the truck and they're taking
it from the original facility the
original data center to the secure
destruction facility now inevitably
there's a lot of data there allegedly
about 12 million records and they get to
take it to the destruction facility in
like months at all up
you know the big sort of tape shredders
there was a bit too much data on the
truck and some of it cannot be accounted
for now there was literally an
honest-to-god statement which said KPMG
who was engaged to try and investigate
what happened retrace to the route of
the truck to determine whether they
could locate the drives along the
wrap-around I would have find any trace
of them and this is like literally
personal data falling off the back of a
truck maybe allegedly or not wasn't
proven but we don't know where it went
so the point is is that even though
we're doing some really cool super
sophisticated security stuff at the same
time we still have really really basic
things that go wrong the number of times
I see things like open s3 buckets even
just yesterday I tweeted a story 11
million records found just in an open s3
bucket just one little configuration
change that went wrong and as soon as
you do that people find your data now
very often these incidents happen due to
the way people create and manage
passwords and I want to spend a bit of
time talking about passwords because
we've done things the same way for a
very long time we've done them very
badly and things are now changing in a
way that most organizations aren't
keeping up with and I like to start with
this photo here so this photo is MIT in
the 60s now the significance of it is
that this is believed to be the first
ever usage of a password on a computer
system now we've had passwords as a
theme for centuries but this was the
first time they're actually used in any
sort of digital capacity now that the
reason why I think this is interesting
is think about the risks that we faced
back then with passwords so who could
get your password and use it well first
of all it had to be someone with
physical access so you had to be able to
get into the room in order to use the
password once you got into the room you
had to know what you're doing it's very
different to today and I reckon if any
of us ended up in that room I don't
think we'd really know what to do I
don't know if it's like tapes or punch
cards or what it is so you had to have
some level of sophisticated not
the other thing is is that there wasn't
a password reuse because there was one
system we never had the problem of using
it in other places so you could use like
your dog's name or something because you
weren't putting it on Facebook or
Twitter or whatever else you could use
your birthdate your kids names but the
mechanism of authentication back then
the idea of having two strings a
username and a password it's
fundamentally the same today it's the
same thing two things in your head if
you have these two strings and they
match when you go to log on you're in
now go forward a couple of decades go
forward like the 80s so when we get to
the 80s we start getting online systems
and this is a pressed Alice a very early
BBS system we end up with about 90,000
people using pressed L and you could
connect remotely from your home and log
into the system when you connect it I've
got a very short clip here from a story
that read on the BBC back in the 80s
that shows you how to authenticate to
press tell so you think of this the
Presto computer is now asking me to
enter my own personal password which I
have now done
that just in case you didn't see this
let's like zoom enhance the slight down
let's have a look at this guy's password
right what's the password now of course
the difference today is you need a
minimum at least six characters so
wherever it's passed was one two three
four five six so this is a problem and
this is humans trying to circumvent the
technology you're gonna see this as a
theme as we go through this password
section it's humans trying to make their
life easier because the technology gets
in the way so this is what people do
they create passwords like this and they
use them all over the place now you
could kind of get away with it even here
because they're only 90,000 people using
the system okay that's like almost
90,000 more than what it was back in MIT
but the point is is that now you've got
lots of other adversaries potential
people who want to break into your
account around the world if we go
forward another couple of decades now
we're into an Internet era okay so now
we're into sort of late 90s naughties we
were starting to get lots of things
online and we started to say well
everyone's creating these passwords that
are like one two three four we have got
to try and fix this problem we've got to
make passwords more complex so that
people don't do stupid things so there's
some file footage here of Bob in the
accounting department and Bob is trying
to sign up to a website which has
password complexity requirements now Bob
needs a password that's got a lowercase
letter an uppercase letter a number and
a non alphanumeric number as well non
alphanumeric character it's got to be at
least eight characters long and it also
can't be one that Bob's used in the last
four password rotations and Bob's losing
his freaking mind
because now it is becoming too hard
simply to create a password so what
happens when people face these
complexity requirements you've all
probably done this and you've all
probably know where it's going they'll
do things like this this is a good
password who thinks it's a good password
because have a think about this meets
the complexity requirements lowercase
uppercase number non alphanumeric is
also 15 characters long this meets all
the mathematical criteria of what is a
good password but we look at it and go
now it's a password and it's a
password because we recognize the
pattern and we as humans know that these
are just well-known words and a little
bit of character substitution but you
could all go back to your place of work
and almost certainly create this
password now if you did that what would
happen in three months time it'll ask
you to change it right so what are you
gonna do you all know what you're gonna
do I know what you do I've seen all your
passwords this is what happens you
increment the number at the end and
remember the better I said the humans
always find their way around the
technology this password is just as bad
as the password before and if you had
the password before you could figure out
this one and you could also figure out
the next one because it's a pattern and
what's happening here is when
organizations are saying you must rotate
your password so that the hackers don't
get you we do this and this is kind of
crazy logic right because think about
what it means
so this mandated password rotation every
three months we're saying a hacker might
get your password but they might be
really busy and they've got family
commitments and things like this and
then they won't come back to the site
for like another three months and
actually try it that's not how it works
they get passwords and they go in and
they exploit them immediately so time
goes by and we keep rotating them I used
to do this when I was in a corporate job
because I did exactly the same thing as
all of you and I actually learned a
trick I could take the number at the end
of my password divide it by 4 and that's
how long I've been in the company do the
maths that works so so this is not a
good way of doing passwords I think
everyone will agree but we're all forced
into this pattern what's happening now
there's a real sort of groundswell of
change and I'm going to show you a few
things related to this is we're starting
to get guidance from organizations like
the NCSC
so this is a national cybersecurity
Center in the UK we have an equivalent
in Canberra called the a CSC and they're
putting out guidance like this only ask
users to change their password on
indication of suspicion of compromised
and this is really different to what
we've been doing and what we still
mostly do today now in fairness they
don't just say just like get rid of
rotation they then say do all this other
stuff and I'm going to show you a
resource in a moment that helps you with
that lots of other things about how can
we recognize what a normal usage
patterns how can we recognize what is
potentially fraudulent activity because
we can be a lot more sophisticated today
and what we could in the 60s when we
invented this thing a big part of the
reason why the likes of the NCSC and
NIST in the u.s. have been very vocal
about the same sort of stuff big part of
the reason why they're saying this is
because they know the habits that people
fall into when they're forced to rotate
passwords regularly so the numbers is
one ok does implement implementing or in
creating the number at the end storing
the password in insufficient ways is
another and I'll give you a good example
of this remember earlier this year there
was that warning that went off in Hawaii
and everyone totally freaked out because
all their iPhones are like yeah the
bombs are coming and everyone lost their
minds rightly so as well and it turned
out to be a false alarm so they've gone
and interviewed this bike and this bloke
was in charge of the Emergency Response
tuner in Hawaii and they got this photo
of him here and he's standing in front
of his his computers and there's
something really alarming on one of
these computers down here they're using
Internet Explorer
and they put their password on a post-it
note on screen it's like double whammy
but this is precisely the sort of thing
that happens right people fall back to
these practices when they're forced into
crazy password management processes one
of the interesting questions I asked
when I go and visit organizations and I
see things like posters on the wall you
know always use a strong unique password
and I'll strict people there and go well
do they give you a pass to it manage
just so that you can actually do that oh
no no no we're good remember it so
you've got to remember every single
password they've all got to be different
and they've all got to be strong and
somehow you're gonna be like a Rain Man
and just figure this out it doesn't make
sense I'll give you a few resources here
because I want to sort of levius and
things are actionable as well last year
I wrote about this passwords evolved
authentication guidance for the modern
era and this takes the NIST advice and
it takes the NCSC advice and also some
advice from Microsoft and one of the
things that I found really interesting
when I read their guidance is so talking
here about corpuses now what this
sentence is saying is that there are
certain passwords that you shouldn't let
your users use a good example of this is
don't let your users use a password that
is the name of your company and people
do this all the time I see it all the
time and I look at data breaches it's
one of the easiest ways I have to verify
the data breach this data breach is
allegedly from Acme core are there lots
of passwords that are Acme core yes okay
it's probably from there they also say
you should not allow passwords obtains
from previous breach corpuses and this
is kind of interesting because they're
saying if there has been a data breach
and there's been passwords that have
been leaked
you shouldn't now allow people to use
those passwords in your systems because
they've got a higher risk of account
takeover and think about what that means
either it's the same person using the
same password in which case their
username and password are already out
there in the Ashley Madison breach or
the Dropbox breach or the LinkedIn
breach or they have chosen a password
which is the same as someone else has
chosen because they have dogs with the
same name or something a name like that
which means it's not a very good
password so NIST said this but they
didn't give you a way of
finding passwords from previous breach
corpuses so on have I been pwned
I built a little thing this is pwned
passwords 517 million unique passwords
from different data breaches real data
breaches
I have passwords in there your passwords
are probably in there you can download
these 517 million passwords and stop
people from using them when they log on
to your system who uses github everyone
right github uses this they rolled this
out just a couple of weeks ago if you
trying change your password on github or
log in with a bad password and it's in
this corpus they'll say hey have I been
poned has your password you probably
don't what he is it there's also an API
and this little implementation here
shows you how the API works so if I
search for say password like this and go
bang what's in there
that passwords been seen fifty thousand
seven hundred and forty nine times you
don't want to use that and in case
you're thinking oh yeah great I just put
my password in and senator some Rando in
the internet running this service
there's a really cool implementation
under this and it's called Kay anonymity
something that CloudFlare came up with
to help this service work so I jump into
the dev tools and I search again for
this and I look at the path that was
actually requested this is all that's
been sent now I just searched for the
word password with a capital P no zero
yet all that's been sent is these five
characters so the way Kay anonymity
works is we take the password we show on
hash it we take the first five
characters of the sha-1 hash and that's
what you see there now I can't tell what
your password is if it was hashed I
could possibly crack it and I could see
it was somewhere else but if I only got
those first five characters of the hash
I've got absolutely no idea what your
cast word is and then the way it works
is when we look at the response over
here in that response every sha-1 hash
that begins with that prefix is returned
and it's just the suffix that's returned
and there's normally just under 500 that
are returned
there we go 496 and then after each one
of those suffixes we've got a number and
that's so many times the passwords
Sene there's about five to six million
queries of this api per day and it's
everyone from Cogan in Australia uses
them through to organizations like Eve
online the massive multiplayer game they
hit there's tens of thousands of times a
day using K anonymity to stop people
from reusing passwords and really the
moral of the story here is we can't use
mathematics we can't say this long and
this many random characters or this many
sort of password complexity things we've
got to use stuff like that so that's
there it's available it's totally free
you can download at all you can hit the
API as much as you want okay so
passwords are a big problem now
passwords get leaked and then ultimately
what tends to happen is passwords have a
value and it's passwords along with
their other personal data our email
addresses our names our birth dates and
that data very frequently ends up in
places like this and this brings us to
the dark web probably sounds scary
doesn't it the dark web I'm pretty sure
that's deliberate dark web sells
headlines this is the LinkedIn data
being sold on a dark web marketplace
called the real deal my daughter is in
there 167 million records a sizeable
chunk of the room here had their data in
there as well so this first popped up a
couple years ago at five Bitcoin which
was a lot less then than what it is now
it was about two and a half grand it was
being sold for and you can see here it's
being sold by a seller called peace of
mind
how do percent positive feedback good
guy so you can buy from peace of mind
with confidence now we're going to talk
quite a bit about dark markup
marketplaces dark web marketplaces
because one of the things that's quite
fascinating about them is that it looks
kind of normal right like it looks like
a normal kind of eBay or Craigslist or
something like that it's just a website
now I'm going to show you a few examples
of some of the not so normal things that
they sell on these marketplaces in just
a moment but just to wrap up the piece
on LinkedIn the bloke responsible for
that did get picked up recently in the
Czech Republic he's going on a holiday
to America for a very long time
apparently he was also responsible for
Dropbox both LinkedIn and Dropbox so not
going to work out very well for him at
all now the real deal has been shut down
and many of these dark web marketplaces
do get shut down after a period of time
many of you probably heard of the Silk
Road the Silk Road was sort of the first
canonical dark web marketplace that ran
for a while then got shut down he's
never getting out of jail and we have
others that follow the real deal was one
Hansa Bay alpha market these dark web
marketplaces pop up they run for a while
the people that run them think they're
invincible and then they get caught one
of them that's still running is this one
this is dream market and and again sort
of going back to the premise of this
looking like a very normal online
marketplace it does I mean all right
they do sell some different stuff
granted but for the most part you know
we've got categories and searches and
things like this
you access it by the tor browser bundle
which is based on Firefox works just
like a normal browser and then when you
get in there you buy stuff like fake
Bulgaria and driver's licenses actually
looks pretty good I mean from here I
don't really don't know what I'm looking
at in terms of fake lives licenses but
you can go on there and buy your
driver's license it's about 93 bucks
I've got to pay in Bitcoin of course
everything's cryptocurrency these days
one of the things that we most
frequently think about with darkweb
marketplaces is drugs and I wanted to
sort of find something that that didn't
kind of lower the tone too much because
drugs can be serious stuff so I found
Trump orange ecstasy tablets makes
partying great again and this is a real
thing and a lot of these marketplaces
sell Trump ecstasy tablets of course
it's ships from the Netherlands ships
worldwide sold by a guy with four point
nine six stars out of five good guy also
some of it does get really nasty things
like this uncut afghan hero and british
dragon now british dragon if we look at
his ratings over here
he's had 1989 pieces of positive
feedback nine neutral and eight negative
so a rather trustworthy vendor and the
thing is is that Trust is a very very
important attribute on a dark web
marketplace because it's not like eBay
where you go oh look I went and bought a
product it wasn't very good I'm going to
make a complaint to the a Triple C you
can't do that in a dark web marketplace
so trust and reputation are enormous ly
important if we follow this guy through
he actually has a forum and he says if
you go to my forum after you buy my
drugs and leave a positive comment I
will give you ten percent more heroin on
your next purchase and the point I'm
making here is that all the normal sort
of marketing financial incentives that
we have aboveboard in the normal sort of
web apply here as well it's got lots of
positive feedback this guy a lot of
five-star ratings like this like don't
but this would be the guy just saying
now the point of all of this is to try
and show you where your data sits
alongside because if I go to the next
screen here's the Adobe data I'm in
there twice my work account and my
personal account only ten bucks
pro tip Google and you'll find this in
about five minutes and I don't mean find
where to buy it you'll find were to
download it because so many people have
copied it and redistributed it exists
everywhere now similar saw the story was
something like this is that database
sold by drunk ninja sounds trustworthy
and our data is sitting there alongside
freaking uncut Afghan heroin being
traded in this way and it happens over
and over and over again it still sort of
blows my mind that this is out there
running almost with impunity so it's an
interesting side of the security story
right the fact that this is what happens
after it all goes wrong let's sort of
change the focus a bit and look at how
we try and stop it from going wrong in
the first place and I thought we'd focus
on this for a bit who knows what this is
no it's a handbag now there's that
there's actually a story about this I've
been doing a bit of stuff with Mozilla
recent we're baking have I been poned
into Firefox which is super cool and
they were saying when we do focus groups
a lot of people actually think that
padlock is a handbag and when you think
about it kind of makes sense because
you're going to go do your shopping what
do you take with you there go so most of
us would think about this and this made
sense up until earlier this month until
chrome removed it and we're going to
talk a little bit a little bit about
this because this is a visual indicator
that implies that or doesn't just imply
but it proves that HTTP is in place now
for a very long time we've been telling
people look for the padlock look for the
green secure text and if you see that
you know the website is safe and you can
trust it I want to show you a short
video this is an advertisement from
Barclays Bank
now Barclays Bank ran this ad started
late last year they got through early
this year
and then their Advertising Standards
Authority forced them to take it down
let's play it and see if you can spot
what's wrong with this
realistic sounding jetpack
you know what I can't do this it's all
rubbish it's a scam you order me you'll
get nothing
look in there you need a padlock when
you pay for stuff if there isn't one the
website could be fake defeat online
Foster's this Christmas what do you
reckon what's wrong with this I mean
other than the fact that crime is still
secure anyone could buy an SSL
certificate there are two things wrong
with that but you're basically right and
I'll get back to the two things I think
that are wrong with that anyone can get
their hands on a free certificate which
would hopefully be TLS because we don't
do it so Silla no there's a semantics
thing you know what I mean
I know what you mean all right so let's
look at this side as an example would
you trust this site it's got a handbag
also you actually read the domain you're
a special kind of user because most of
them don't read the domain and actually
there's a true story and this is part of
why Chrome's for making changes because
they know that people either a don't
read the domain or B don't understand
the domain but obviously what you're
picking up on is the obfuscation there
and if I remove the obfuscation it
doesn't look so legit anymore but it
kind of looks like Netflix calm a little
bit enough that once you put it with the
branding as well and you put it with the
padlock on the secure text and
everything else this is a very
convincing phishing page and this is a
domain validator certificate all you
need to do is prove you control the
domain and you get a padlock and this
makes fishing a lot easier because
people have been trained like barclays
ads suggests to look for the padlock and
as I said if you look if you see the
padlock they sort of invert it the other
way they said if you don't see the
padlock it might not be legit
ergo if you do see the padlock then it's
legit right so we have stuff like this
and one of the big reasons that we have
a lot of stuff like this these days is
because of these guys who uses let's
encrypt all right let's try make this
everyone by next year because let's
encrypt is awesome and they're awesome
because they're free automates
an open everyone gets what free means
right you no longer pay for certificates
if you are paying any money whatsoever
for certificates that includes you guys
CBA you're doing it wrong and we'll talk
about evey in a moment bear with me it
is free and they work identically to the
ones that you pay big bucks for
automated means that you can build in
the process of issuance and renewal such
that it happens automatically without
thinking about it and there are loads of
companies including Microsoft on
multiple occasions that have forgotten
to renew certificates you know how in
software development and in technology
in general we sort of go if you have to
do something frequently and it's
important you should automate it this is
kind of important and you do have to do
it frequently either annually with most
certificates or quarterly with let's
encrypt because their certificates last
for three months it's open so anyone can
integrate it so there are loads of our
web service providers out there these
days who say come and get your website
click the button here and then you will
get a lepton certificate for free
and will renew it automatically now this
presents a new problem and the problem
is this certificate authorities for the
longest time have sold these
certificates and now they're free so how
do you think the certificate authorities
feel about this maybe not so happy
they're like we had a good thing going
we'd get 70 bucks a year or something we
do it R&R again and it was awesome
because you didn't just buy it once you
had to buy it every single year and we
had this great revenue stream now these
bastards that come along and I've done
the whole thing for free not so happy
about it let me give you an example of
why they're not happy I'll write
something last year about evie certs and
phishing and things we got to talk about
even in a moment and there was a really
interesting tweet down here this bloke
in fact will jump back up a little bit
there where was he
Mel I with the last name I'm not going
to have a shot at but Mel I was the CEO
of Komodo now at the time he said look
here is a Netflix phishing site do you
see the secure logo on the phishing site
and what the commercial CAS have tried
to do is discredit let's encrypt by
issuing
tickets to fishing sites because I said
look you're bad by issuing certificates
to fishing sites
the thing is is that encryption is
morally neutral encryption doesn't make
any assertions about whether you're a
good dude or a bad dude it's just like
are you dude who owns the domain if yes
then you meet the criteria so he wasn't
real happy about that and you know the
interesting thing here is he sort of put
that tweet out and then down a little
bit further he had another tweet just
here here's another one secure one of
course my daughter's secured these
fishes aren't they why does this tweet
look different to the tweet above it's
deleted it
why would you delete the tweet could it
possibly be that the CEO of comodo
pointed to a phishing site that uses a
certificate from komodo and as Eric
Lawrence pointed out just after this
Eric Lawrence is the guy who created
fiddler he said when when you work at a
CI you need a phishing site to make a
point choose one for which our
competitors supply the certificate now
let's be honest this is funny you're all
laughing the reality of it is is that
when you look at phishing sites and
who's issuing them comodo we're winning
until recently and incidentally like
this is kind of like golf right you
really want to lower score but comodo
was leading the charge up until sometime
last year and then let's encrypt as they
got bigger and bigger and bigger and
they're now the world's largest issuing
CA by a long way they now issue my
phishing site because their allows your
organization this is just the nature of
it and it's funny because people lose
track of the fact that this happens so
if we jump back to here for a second and
we'll move this discussion on a bit
whose website is this
all right apples now see thank you for
speaking up because I think everyone
else is like I want to say I poor but if
I say up which was gonna tell me I'm
wrong so yeah you're wrong it's not
Apple this is an ID in homograph so an
international the internationalized
domain name homograph it is letters that
look like they should be Apple but
they're not Apple and this is Firefox if
I put crime here you see something quite
different and just to show you like this
is not some sort of magic trick if I
jump over here here's the example in
chrome right looks like that
if I grab that and we open up Firefox
let's plug it into their magic look at
that isn't that cool now this also
speaks to the point I made just before
about humans can't look at the address
bar and make any sort of rational
informed decision about whether the site
is safe because we would all fall for
that we would all say that that is Apple
so this is a problem and the way many
organizations try to solve the problem
certainly the way the commercial CAS
would like you to solve the problem is
they say you should get an AV
certificate an extended validation
certificate now let me show you how an
extended validation certificate works
we'll jump back to here we'll go over to
Komodo you see something different there
to the other sites so I have a look at
the name here we've got kimono security
our data yarder if we go back to my blog
all we get now is a padlock so while
we're here let's just sort of clearly
make this point chrome 69 shipped
earlier this month in chrome 69 they
removed the secure text they removed all
the green bits and now you just get a
padlock they did also remove the scheme
in the www and then everyone got very
very upset so they put it back but we
still have no secure text and we still
have no green remember that because we
gonna come back to green things now when
you get an extended validation
certificate like this you have to jump
through a lot of hurdles to prove who
you are you need a legally registered
business entity you have to be
registered in business directives
directories you have to have phone calls
with the CA to prove who you are and
they will get documents from you I had
one for ever being pwned until yesterday
and I'm gonna explain why I don't
anymore and when I got that
I had to have a Skype video call with
digi cert hold my password up next to my
face smile took photo me right like
prove who you are now the commercial CA
is like extended validation certificate
because they can still sell them there
is work involved this is not an
automated process and they will tell you
you should get one because if you have
one people will stay on your site longer
they'll buy more stuff they'll actually
check out with that shopping cart and it
stops fishing because a phishing site
can't get one of these now let's try and
experiment there this is always fun with
with an audience if the position is that
in order to let people know that you're
authentic in order for people to trust
you that you should have an Eevee
certificate then the sites that we know
and use the big important ones will have
these certificates who thinks Facebook
has an Eevee certificate come on
right no one will use Facebook who think
there's a DV certificate that's like
zero plus two all right so let's let's
try the experiment because this does
make sense when you see it so if we go
to Facebook Facebook has e V DV rather
so we don't see facebook.com so if the
commercial certificate authority is the
same look you should look for Eevee in
order to trust the site but one of the
world's largest websites doesn't do it
it doesn't make sense now this is social
media though so what if we go shopping
what about eBay who thinks eBay has
Eevee okay so now there are hands going
up right let's go here eBay now there's
no Eevee on eBay now here's the point
and this is the this is the rhetorical
question for the people who put their
hands on Eevee certificates will only
work if you change your behavior when
you don't see it you thought this had
Eevee if you go here and see DV will you
leave now you won't otherwise you'd
never buy anything from eBay because
they don't have it and even today I had
people arguments me saying Eevee is
really important because it reduces the
risk of phishing and if you see the
thing there
in the title you'll know that it's a
legitimate site and I was like well
let's say I want to mount a phishing
attack but we'll try PayPal because
PayPal does have Eevee okay whoops paper
like that
all right PayPal you'll see has oh well
this took a turn for the in a way I did
not expect certificates isn't that
interesting
why does PayPal no longer have Eevee
quick put out a tweet okay let's do cba
because I know CBA does we're looking at
them yesterday
it's just that caught on the room isn't
it cba to come today you okay so CBA has
levy a lot of banks have Eevee now
people would make the argument that if
you go here you'll know that it's CBA
and you'll trust it more but the
question I put to you is if I stand up a
website with the domain that looks very
similar to this and I get a DB
certificate and I still have the padlock
will CBA customers go there and say well
I'm not seeing Eevee I'm gonna leave
no they won't and that's the only way
Eevee would work if people change their
behavior when they didn't see it and
they don't therefore it doesn't work
there are other reasons why it doesn't
work as well that's not my slide show
this one which company is this stripe
okay yes correct very good what does
stripe do no they don't there is a
stripe that does card transactions a
stripe you can have more than one stripe
in America every single state can have a
different stripe and if you have a legal
registered business entity and you can
meet all the requirements for an a/v
certificate you can go and get a
certificate too which is what this guy
in Carroll did he went and got a
certificate for stripe Inc because he
has a legal registered entity called
stripe ink that doesn't mean it's the
stripe ink that you guys think it is so
see how this like just continually
messes with your head like you're seeing
one thing but it means something
different and keep in mind as well like
we are here because we are all smart
technical people and we're aware
of basically the way browsers and
websites and things work we are not
representative of the masses so if we
don't get this right what are the
chances everyone else will all right
let's continue the the eveything so this
is an ssl reseller it is the ssl store
we know that because there's a massive
logo that says be ssl store the URL says
the ssl store I've blanked out the evie
name what's the AV name gonna be the ssl
store no it's something different and
now i'm confused more confused than if I
just sort of had luck because I went
here thinking I was at the ssl store and
the CA said I have to look for the name
and if I don't see the name I can't
trust it I should go somewhere else and
now I'm seeing a name that I don't
recognize and this happens because
there's a legal entity that owns the ssl
store that has a different name and it's
not a name that's recognizable because
of all this because of the confusion
because of the problems it causes we're
heading in this direction this is from
the NDC security event on the Gold Coast
earlier this year I run a workshop and
there were three machines in my workshop
where chrome did this did not show Eevee
and these people are part of Google's
experiment to remove Eevee because
they're seriously looking at getting rid
of it all together only a few weeks ago
someone sent me this at the time have I
been poned had Eevee and they said hey
Troy this is interesting look it looks
just like DV now and then here as part
of the experiment chrome temporarily
shows only the lock icon in the address
bar your SSL certificate with accept SSL
TLS certificate where the extent of
validation is still valid they know it
doesn't work Google knows it doesn't
work so they're testing getting rid of
it
this is Safari on iOS
two days ago this is Safari on iOS
yesterday so the difference because iOS
12 shipped yesterday and in iOS 12 that
moved it they don't do like subtle
testing like Google and look for
community feedback apples just like
screw you dudes like it's going that's
it so it's gone so now you don't see the
company name anymore now here's the
significance of these three screens I
just showed if you are telling customers
to look for the business name and they
use Safari on iOS and incidentally
chrome and iOS does the same thing
they're not going to see it so what's
going to happen to your customers you
can't tell your customers this anymore
this is my blog on Safari on iOS 12 do
you see the difference I'll go back
what's different color it's green so you
could tell your customers make sure you
look for the green URL and then one of
them goes and uses Chrome which is
probably quite likely and you don't have
green anymore so there's all of these
screwy nuances about what we're telling
people to look for in terms of TV now
it's worse than this like let's like
it's almost dead but let's just finish
it off here's a good example I've got a
little video here which is a promotional
piece from komodo which is explaining to
people why they should have Eevee it's a
little short clip here it's part of a
larger video let's have a look visitors
to a site with an Eevee SSL Certificates
see their browser address bar turn green
whenever they are on a secure or HTTPS
page typically among the most critical
during a session right at the moment of
truth when they're weighing whether or
not to go forward with a transaction the
striking visual indicator accompanied by
information certifying their business
name location and the certification
authority that validated it is presented
providing needed reassurance to continue
right at the moment of truth look for
the green now this video is something
that they're actively still sharing
today it is an old video but this is
still the position they make and they
say look for the green and they show
Excalibur Excalibur is an online
marketplace that's their poster child
for Eevee
this is Excalibur today and just a rub
salt in the wounds let's make sure we
can see everything in its glory here
they know it doesn't work maybe Komodo
cut him a deal or something or like the
CEO got drunk with the CEO of Komodo or
so like I'm struggling to find a good
reason why they did it in the first
place but clearly sanity has prevailed
let's do another one someone forwarded
me this this month so their certificate
was due for renewal and they got
forwarded an email like this and there's
this bit here that says boost online
sales with Eevee and it talks about
mostly dead calm and it shows the green
bar incidentally there's no green bar
anymore unless you're anything to
explore and who the hell's on Internet
Explorer so let's have a look at mostly
dead have a closer look that's encrypted
DV so even the sites that were the
poster child for Eevee have gotten those
edges doesn't work you know like we
don't need this we will go back to DV
all the cryptography is the same the
security is the same you have automated
renewal there's no manual stuff there's
no money involved there's just no good
reasons left other than just simply not
knowing what you're doing okay so I
think we've sort of beat Eevee to death
about as far as we can but let me leave
you with sort of one final thought on
this and it's this this is the value
proposition of Eevee easy depends on you
doing something different in the absence
of a positive visual indicator and you
won't you guys won't and if you won't
the masses out there won't now let's
change base because I want to talk about
some IRT stuff and I want to talk about
an incident I was involved in last year
because it's sort of some really
interesting things we can learn from
this and I thought maybe a nice sort of
transition from like useless security to
IOT would be to talk very briefly about
this this is an IOT padlock you can
Bluetooth your phone
it uses a thumbprint reader to unlock it
it has a screw on the outside there's a
guy called the lockpick lawyer and he
gets this sort of stuff and he pulls it
apart and then he does tear downs on how
they don't work and the screw does what
you're probably thinking it does it
unlocks the padlock so he's God and
submitted this to the organization said
look I'd like to see a responsible
disclosure etc your padlock can kind of
be circumvented and they came back to
him and said well well actually the
padlock is invincible to people who do
not have a screwdriver this is a real
thing somehow this is just like
indicative of the security industry or
us like this thing works under this
circumstance which never happens which
is probably a good segue for me actually
keeping the theme going on connected
things I thought I'd talk a little bit
about this has anyone got an s and leaf
had an s and leaf we'll come back to him
so this is an S and leaf we don't see
many of the minister I believe they do
sell them they have a lot of them in
Norway the home of NDC and I was in
Norway a couple of years ago doing some
workshops and I did one as part of NDC
and one of the guys in my workshop we do
this exercise where you proxy your
mobile device through your PC and then
you look at the traffic from the mobile
device so you can actually it's kind of
like the equivalent of going f12 and
seeing your dev tools but you get to see
it on a mobile app and he had one of
these cars and the car comes with the
companion app and one of the things I
learned while I was in Norway in January
is it's really freaking cold and it's so
cold that they need to use this app to
turn the heater on in the car before
they get in there otherwise it's too
cold so this bloke was curious he
thought well how does my phone know how
to talk to my car how does it identify
my car is that like a bearer token or
something so a proxy DS traffic through
Fidler and he watched it and he was
looking for the API key he wanted to
know what is the API key he discovered
that the API key
is printed in the windscreen of every
car because it's the VIN number
now this after we laughed a little bit
was something that we said okay we need
to prove this is actually a risk and
what we discovered is that the VIN
number is a combination of the
manufacturer the country of manufacturer
the plant the year and then pretty much
the last five digits there I've blanked
out because this does effectively give
you some control of someone else's car
the last five digits are innumerable so
you can just keep guessing and finding
other cars so we found another car and
we managed to pull back information
about the battery status and the trip
history and we went okay this is a good
place to stop we could go through and
just start turning on like the aircon
and the heater on every single Nissen
that was connected let's stop there and
we'll report it to Nissen we'll do the
right thing so i reported to them and i
had a phone call with them and they were
very interested at first and we spoke
backwards and forwards we had a phone
call didle a bunch of emails for about a
week and then everything went really
quiet and it's just like they lost
interest and I just kept getting this
distinct feeling that this is something
that they would rather not talk about
for pretty obvious reasons and then I
discovered online almost a month later I
discovered that other people had found
the same vulnerability and the reason
they discovered it is that apparently
the app is terrible and people were
saying the app is so slow to load it's a
pain in the ass and you got to click
through all the menus and things all I
want to do is turn the heater on here's
what you do go to this URL change the
VIN number to your own put it in your
bookmarks and while you're all toasty in
bed just go to the bookmark on your
phone job done heater turns on there's
probably people out here going well that
shouldn't be a get request that's
changing state because you just turned
the heater on and I'm reading this going
do you not know what you have found
because you have just found the secret
source to turn on the heater and
everyone's car so I went back to Nessun
said look I'm going to write about this
it's going to be public you know do you
have anything else to say they said
please don't say well do you have
anything else to say and that the thing
is is that whenever I sought to do
something like this and it gets media
attention that I'll go try and find this
right balance where
you want it to be impactful enough that
it drives change you want things to
actually get better so you've got to
make sure that it gets picked up by the
media but you don't want to sensational
eyes it so you've got to find the sweet
spot somewhere in between and what I
discovered is that Scot helm who's
actually coincidentally down here Scot
helm is based in the UK and Scot helm
had anise and leaf and we tested this
whole thing and it did actually work so
I said okay let's do a video so I went
home to the Gold Coast and I sat near my
pool he's in England which is why he
looks cold and miserable and I said okay
look we'll do this thing where I will
control your car from the Gold Coast and
we'll record it and I'll show you a
little bit of the clip from the start
then is that see what I can control from
this end and I guess the the first thing
is I can see that you're going to be jet
run it's cold there should we look at
what we might be able to do if the
heater so if we can bring out to
Australia temps for a little bit now
what we did then is I went and hit the
URL that turned on his heating now I'm
not showing this publicly before because
when I originally did this the
vulnerability was still there but this
is the full URL there's a get request
there's he's been number he's since sold
the car so I'm not daxing your car has
to be clear and this is all you do you'd
hit this and then once you hit that
you'd get a response back state is 200
so that's worked ok success it actually
leaks his user ID as well so if you
could enumerate through VIN numbers you
could pull user IDs and then get a
little bit closer to understanding who
the person was it under now let's have a
look at what happens when I hit this
because Scott got a bit of in-car video
and remember you could do this to
anyone's car from anywhere in the world
it's beeping oh there we go no my heated
seats have come on the phones of just
come on as well you can see there's a
status indicator on the dash or the cars
currently been controlled remotely which
is now blinking and I'm not sure if you
can hear that
all powers Eisley quite wild indian and
that was it and an amazing thing
happened after I put the blog post out
and this and suddenly decided it was
important don't no way I think it might
have been all the journalists who
started writing stories about car
hacking and the thing went offline very
very quickly and to be clear this was
never about controlling the steering or
the brakes or anything that would kill
someone but it gets the car hacking
headline so it becomes important so they
took it offline and it went down for a
long time I was like six weeks or
something
Norwegians had to get out of bed to turn
the heater on in the car eventually they
put it back online and they pushed out a
new app and this is the app and Scott
actually sent me this he said have a
look at the app so if you see anything
wrong with the app and I looked at it
carefully and I um did a little bit down
the bottom and it will see anything
unusual for an app that controls a car
cut and paste from stack overflow
so we discovered that as part of their
fix and that mind you this may explain
why it took six weeks to fix um that
should have been simple as well they cut
and pasted code from Stack Overflow and
we actually found the code we found the
stack overflow question over here it's
still there today there it is
someone had cut and paste this without
realizing what it did and now was
controlling part of a car and it was
even worse than that because what does
this word say what does that word say so
they hadn't even cut and paste it
someone had literally retyped this and
had no idea what it did and it's
controlling a car now when this happened
not everyone was real happy about it
because some people had to get out of
bed to turn their car on one person got
particularly upset with me and they left
this review on the Google Play Store
and he says thanks to the actions of
publication from a rather stupid
researcher Tory hunt at least in the UK
has any car wings car wings was the name
of the app so basically he got very
upset that I had reported the
vulnerability and I saw this and I
wondered how to react because I'm a
little bit pissed off if I'm honest it's
like look I actually tried to do the
right thing here and there you're
getting upset with me for basically
trying to save you guys and then it
reminded me that there are people like
this out there who need saving from
themselves so I decided to print it out
and frame and put on my desk it's still
there today here it's a lot a reminder
people need help because there are all
sorts of things in our lives
digital connected things connected to
the cyber that continually go wrong
which leads me through to one more now
this is this is a fun one and what I
would normally say when I start this is
so looking going to talk about something
here it's in Japanese I don't know what
it says when I did this talk very
recently someone actually translated
some of the next images for me now I
can't tell you here what the translation
said you'll see why in a moment if you
want to know come back and grab me later
and I'll tell you this is a connected
toilet there is such a thing it's called
a LIXIL satus and you get your
smartphone and you bluetooth it to the
toilet so that you can control features
of the toilet
this is Japanese if you've been to Japan
you'll know why this just fits the mold
just perfectly and I was curious when I
saw this because I went why would you do
this like what is the value proposition
of Bluetooth thing to your toilet I mean
let's face it you have proximity anyway
you know it's not like you're trying to
remotely control something so I went and
pulled down some images from the app to
try and understand what it actually did
now all of these are real images you can
find them online they're not adulthood
and as best I can tell the first image
is some form of a splash screen oh come
on
the middle image I find particularly
fascinating this is the one I've had
translated but I can't really say what I
was on the stage it is some form of
event-driven data I can say that much it
is legit it's out there the image on the
right is a music player and again I have
not modified these images the music
player has the toilet playing I can't
get no satisfaction Google LIXIL status
you'll find this trust me so I saw this
pop up a few years ago and I thought
this would make an interesting part of a
talk because I can say to people that as
we start to connect things we're going
to have new vulnerabilities the kind we
have never seen before and not so long
ago Trustwave the security company
popped up and said well we actually
found a vulnerability that vulnerability
could allow our attackers to cause the
unit to unexpectedly activate badeah
rare drive functions causing discomfort
or distress which i think is an
absolutely terrifying concept thank you
now hey I have a couple of minutes left
as well for questions if anyone would
like to ask any questions
possibly not related to the toilet are
there any questions yes
every certificate don't fix fishing what
does user behavior which we can't fix
okay this is sort of part of the problem
we really don't have a good answer baked
in the browser because most of the
answers you hear such as Eevee depend on
the user behaving differently under a
set of circumstances they're not very
well equipped to diagnose so easy
definitely doesn't fix it
one of the things that does fix it is
getting phishing sites submitted very
quickly to the likes of Google Safe
Browsing so have you ever been to a web
site yeah accidentally maybe it was a
phishing you've accidentally clicked the
link and like the whole screen is red
that fixes phishing so if we could get
that stuff in there earlier on you'll
also find that very often your carrier
I've certainly seen it on tell straw
will flag phishing sites very early so
the sooner we get them flagged and that
depends on people doing things like
submitting malicious sites to Google
Safe Browsing the sooner we get that
happening the better and that works
whether there's HTTPS or no HTTPS or
anything else beyond that the normal
user behaviors also we've got a
condition people the right way so I did
a talk recently where I showed an ANZ
email that I had received and the aliens
that email was saying we've got a new
mobile app fear iPhone we'd like you to
download it and looking at this gun I
got an email from a bank saying go and
download software right what I'll do is
I put my finger on the link and I'll
hold it there very very carefully
because I don't want to touch it too
quickly otherwise I'll go there I'll
hold it there and I'll see what happens
and it pops up with some really screwed
domain marketing kind of link and I'm
like this is not good at all but I'll
follow it anyway because hey so I follow
it and then it goes to an Adobe page
because it's using Omniture for
analytics and then eventually it does go
through to the App Store it's a
legitimate app but I said to Sano's I
was like this demonstrates every single
negative thing that we tell people to
look for in terms of phishing signs so
unfortunately we're not doing very well
as organizations to condition people to
do the right thing either
other questions
how do I know it was a legitimate app
okay very good question so here's how I
think I know we didn't it up I closed it
and I went to the App Store and I
searched for ANZ and I found one from a
publisher called A&Z that had lots of
ratings and then I hoped but you know
like this this is probably the best
thing we have at the moment I mean
honestly legitimate app stores like the
Apple App Store the Google Play does get
a few funky things around then but going
to legitimate app stores you're much
better equipped to go to that store
which is curated some people get upset
unless there's a walled garden which it
is to a degree but you go there and you
download the app you're much better
equipped to do that then try and get the
URL right and hope you go to the correct
website anyone else all right well in
that case thank you very much for coming
[Applause]